And because they can live up to 100 years old,
giant clams make vital indicators of coral reef health.
So when giant clams start to disappear from coral reefs,
their absence can serve as an alarm bell
for scientists to start paying attention,
similar to the canary in a coal mine.
But giant clams are endangered.
The largest clam in the world is facing the threat of extinction,
with more than 50 percent of the wild population severely depleted.
And the ecological benefits of having giant clams on coral reefs
are likely to continue only if populations are healthy,
making their conservation paramount.
So I stand here today to give a voice to the giant clams,
because I care a whole lot for these amazing animals,
and they deserve to be cared for.
It is time for the giant clams to step out of their shells,
and show the world that they, too, can be the heroes of the oceans.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)